non
c'est tout
ce
d'accord
bon
ce
le manoir
laura la st
je sais
m battant
la
liste
le dge a paralysé
je veux
personne
m
les verts sont aussi les plus élégantes
devant cette fermeture
à
la soirée parce que
mieux vous
serez
témoins
joli
ce que
voilà le groupe n derrière vonn
ouais
[Musique]
est ce qu'on va faire
quand en convenir
je m'en sors
ici on peut parler les retraités monde
selon m
pourquoi
m
fava
enfin
non
la maison
tout résident tous
d'autres
lamy
or
super
nous demandons
un quotidien
on parlera comme
cette fois
je tiens
c'était l'un des grands acteurs français
les obsèques de gaspard ulliel on lui à
paris ce jeudi
dans le 1er arrondissement de paris à
l'église sainte eustache vous pouvez le
voir sur ces images avec de nombreux
proches qui sont présents la cérémonie
aura lieu à 11 heures je suis avec
bertrand guyard ben bernanke hier
jean-christophe figaro culture bonjour
bertrand bonjour on va revenir pendant
ce live sur la carrière de gaspard
ulliel vous n'hésitez pas dans le chat à
nous poser vos questions vous êtes très
nombreux à
réagir à être très triste on peut le
voir je vois par exemple charles dit
qu'elle tristesse comment peut-on perdre
la vie à ce moment là c'est voilà on va
on va parler alors que caen viard vient
d'arriver bertrand est ce qu'on va
parler déjà un peu de de gaspard ulliel
comment on peut définir sa carrière à
gaspard gay mais elle est
malheureusement à l'image tragique de sa
vie elle et elle aimait théorique mais
en peu de temps un peu de temps ils
meurent a donc à 37 en peu de temps ils
marquent quand même l'histoire du cinéma
j aurai du cinéma français il a même
fait déployer là et même eu le temps de
faire des grandes productions
internationales c'est c'est quelqu'un
qui cale
qui reçoit le césar du meilleur espoir
masculin et l'âge 20 ou 21 ans et reçoit
un peu plus de 30 ans le césar du
meilleur acteur tout court
ichou il est quand même à la fiche
premiers rôles ou premier j'irai où il a
des rôles très importants dans quatre ou
cinq films qui ont marqué les deux
dernières décennies c'est quelque chose
d'assez exceptionnel et puis évidemment
la fin de sa vie tragique de mourir
comment dirais-je on ne meurt jamais
intelligemment mais de mourir bêtement
dans un banal accident de ski on sait
maintenant que ces sommes certainement
un accident bête hein c'est sur des
pistes bleues il cogne akon quelqu'un et
lui meurt quasiment pas sur le coup mais
il a un traumatisme
et ça
choque les gens surtout qu'il était
jeune il était beau sa mort a été
effectivement un choc avec très suivie
comment expliquer cette défaite c'était
une grande popularité de cet acteur baba
encore une fois il y reçoit le césar à 2
en 2010 est donc très récemment pour
pour juste la fin du monde de oz aviez
dolan et puis il est le héros romantique
oui on peut pas dire ça autrement demain
d'un
son 1er au dimanche de fiançailles de
genêts où il incarne là aussi alors
c'est ainsi qu'en dh chez c1
ce qu'est ce qui est assez étonnant
quand même danse alors après on essaie
toujours d'interpréter les filmographies
mais il a choisi c'est quand même il a
eu une carrière très courte mais en même
temps très très éclectique frais choisi
un et dans ce premier film finalement
qu'il a qui le révèle
il est il incarne un héros anti héros
cssf fameux fameux soldats de la
première guerre mondiale qui était qui
était un grand massacre pour pour la
population française plus que
paradoxalement que la seconde guerre
mondiale et
aya il a ce visage 1 il a ce visage et
en même temps je dirais juvénile et
viril juvénile parce qu'il était très
jeune mais il a gardé sa jusqu'à jusqu'à
ces derniers jours c'est à dire un
visage on sait avec cette fameuse
fawcett qui était une petite balafre
là il est allé c'est une photo récente
que vous pouvez voir à 35 36 ans mais il
a un regard effectivement il a un regard
bleu il a un regard des il peut jouer
hannibal lecter il peut jouer un héros
complètement
presque naïf et il peut jouer hannibal
lecter jeunes c'est justement un peu sa
carrière tu le disais il se fait il se
déploie le grand public sur un long
dimanche de fiançailles a pris il va
tourner et hannibal lecter dans une
production internationale oui bien sûr
donc c'est pas si facile que ça parce
que je l'aï dit il ya dans le monde
parce que dans le genre de gars là c'est
on veut relancer l'histoire c'est qu'on
veut relancer l'histoire de ce serial
killer
une très intelligent joué par anthony
hopkins et au fond on fait ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui après qu elle on
essaie de revenir aux origines du mal
d'ailleurs je crois que le film et est
sous titré au vos origines du mal et on
essaye de comprendre pourquoi cet homme
a dérivé vers 20 vers la mégalomanie et
la mégalomanie meurtrière surtout en
l'occurrence web pour hannibal lecter et
donc lui il assume quand même de jouer
ce rôle j'ai regardé j'avais déjà vu le
film
quelqu'un que je conseille pas aux plus
jeunes aux seins nus aux plus jeunes ou
même aux âmes sensibles où
on va papa de ce film et ce film lui et
lui et je trouve très bon ulliel mais
c'est vrai que le la réalisation le fait
un peu surjouée dans dans une sorte de
cl une sorte de machiavélisme
sanguinaire c'est quelque chose de fou
mais lui en tout cas revenons on n'est
pas là pour parler du ce film là on
n'est pas là on est là pour parler du
miel
vie il assume il assume ça donc c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui
je crois il est il était aussi quelque
chose d'autre qui m'a qui m'a marqué
c'est que il est donc encore une fois
c'est sa carrière à sa carrière leimer à
37 ans il fait et d'aidés dès l'âge de
20 ans il est vrai il est déjà un acteur
reconnu finalement dès son premier film
donc tout ça se passe très rapidement et
donc il n'a pas le temps il fait 6
passes qui passent le bac
et puis s'inscrit quand même en fac pour
faire dans une fac de cinéma pour une
page croyez réussi une première année de
drogue puis très vite on lui confie des
rôles relativement important
donc ils arrêtent tout ça et preuve de
quand même de son perfectionnisme c'est
qu'au fond il va tout de suite est
devant la caméra devant au cinéma oui
très très tôt ça arrive finalement ce
rôle bah oui et donc la plupart
finalement la plupart des acteurs ils
sont j'irai d'ailleurs au comédien au
théâtre
on
fait ses armes sur les tréteaux est lui
en revanche la firme inverse a très vite
il va essayer il va monter il va faire
de hiva il va jouer dans deux pièces de
théâtre avec michel faut quelqu'un qui
est très reconnue
dans ce milieu et il voulait je crois
que c'était quelqu'un qui voulait
réellement
il était perfectionniste il voulait
montrer le meilleur le meilleur de lui
même dans son dense et métier d'acteur
oui et puis tu l'as en parlait il ya cet
éclectisme de pouvoir jouer un peu un
peu tout d'aider des rôles assez
différents les uns des autres bah c'est
encore une fois il il a plutôt un fille
il a une beauté très moderne un an le
voilà d'ailleurs c'est assez touchant là
il a une vingtaine d'années il est il
allé oui on ne peut pas dire alors mais
il ya un côté
récemment on a parlé de belmondo jeunes
il est représentait il a représenté lui
la nouvelle vague une veine forme de
beauté et lui représenter une autre
forme de beauté un peu un peu bas
rebelles je dirais un peu un peu bohème
un peu un peu différente en tout cas
c'est le choix
des réalisateurs qui a abandonné paris
sur lui et ne se trompe pas quand même
hein ils se trompent pas donc alors faut
revenir à votre question initiale c'est
pourquoi pour pourquoi les gens ont été
touchés pourquoi les gens ont été
touchés encore une fois parce qu'il
était en pleine à son qu'il était en
pleine ascension c'est quelqu'un qui est
fauché en pleine ascension
il va certainement et être un il est
déjà un acteur très très marquant très
important il va du travail il fait
attention à ce qui fait la mana il a les
moyens de faire ça et un banal un banal
accident de ski lahrache à la vie on
peut paraître dans des films qui a été
majeur pour lui c'est saint laurent à
frêche
tout ça c'est c'est bien que les césar
les attributions de césar pourquoi
comment c'est vraiment effective aille
ailleurs niney je crois que je je je
crois que ni nez avec bo de bons
rapports avec lui qu effectivement tout
ça cette rivalité a été montée bas par
nos journalistes et ce qu'il faut bien
faut bien créer une compétition une
prime il en apparaît d'ailleurs il me
semble hors du lors de son discours en
ce que c'était il semblait amis à côté
malgré cette facette cette réalité oui
c'était il était habillé forcément
rivaux et concurrents puisque lisons des
des physique comparable dh comparables
une palette de jeu peut-être comparables
elles sont différents quand même
différent lui était plus était plus je
pense ulliel était plus dans dans une
époque au fond c'était plutôt l'époque
des années c'est un homme des années 80
un peu il est resté resté un peu bohème
il est resté un peu et c'est difficile
de parler de lui moi je le connaissais
pas du tout personnellement mais c'est
vrai aussi qu'il est resté discret
c'était quelqu'un qui visiblement ne
jouez pas le jeu de ah on voit qu'elle
catherine deneuve qui arrive
à ses obsèques et
il est resté discret il est resté
c'était quelqu'un qui visiblement jouait
pas du tout le jeu de la presse people
justement il est il il a une
filmographie très très impressionnante
mais en même temps il n'a pas de jouer
de non plus dans dans dans énormément de
films oui enfin on y
voit la première vont par exemple il
m'est venu à l'esprit c'est gérard
philipe qui meurent à 38 ou 39 ans
il arrive analysons une filmographie ici
on peut regarder il joue quand même une
en ça commence on peut dire si mission
un long dimanche de fiançailles c'est
2004 il meurt 18 ans après il fait
pendant pendant ce temps là il faut déjà
une vingtaine de grands films une
vingtaine par an à peu près 8 et gadea
et en même temps ils veulent jouer au
théâtre
on peut regarder son cv enfin s'est il
fait des téléfilms et des séries fait
des courts métrages
dans ces incroyables quand même alors il
fait non effet énorme m il travaille
beaucoup il travaille beaucoup il est je
cite là puisque j'avais pas tout ça en
tête mais il a il a fait 1 en 2004 il
fait un épisode de navarro il a fait la
série mister mocky présente mister mocky
présente alors ça ça prouve car là il
s'est déjà en 2009 c'est déjà il a déjà
un nom donc il sait vers quoi les
non non il élit les hôtes
à la télé il fait aussi un la vengeance
au triple galop d'axel d'alex lutz
bon non il est il travaille quand même
énormément il travaille alors il
travaillait en plus
il est égérie de la maison
pioneer effectivement parce qu'alors il
ya ça aussi que je vais parler c'est que
le grand public alors il ya ces films
bien évidemment mais quand qu'on revoie
il ya surtout cette pub iconique de
chanel qu'on est en train de passer
qu'il a fait vraiment qui passait
partout et qu'il a fait vraiment aussi
pas exposé parce qu'il était déjà très
connu mais qui a assoupli ainsi sa
présence on va dire
ça passe dans le monde entier alors
aujourd'hui mais est-ce que ça participe
et de ça mais là il est très beau c'est
ça vous montrions il est quand même très
beau là dessus il a il a ce visage
j'irai à quimper long à couper au
couteau
ara gars qui peut être effectivement par
frick et bleu qui peut être légèrement
romantique un parfois un peu intense il
ya quelque chose d'ailleurs c'est là les
publicitaires ne seront en gironde ils
se trompent pas vous avez les choisit
débat sérieux bah je vais à romy
schneider ou catherine deneuve convient
de voir un mec quand elle était plus
jeune que tous tous et tous ont été ont
été happés par la publicité donc parce
qu'ils savent où johnny depp aussi un
c'est aussi j'ai sur un johnny depp
enfin on pourrait citer quasiment tous
parce que les acteurs alors d'abord il
est comme vous l'avez dit justement il
est déjà il est déjà connu à ce moment
là donc c'est du marketing et ils savent
que ils peuvent compter là dessus sur
cette reconnaissance et puis
effectivement il ya quand même il est
dans la publicité qu'on vient de voir
il a un chat il a un charme viril d'un
autre
garder au fond c'est tournée s'est
tourné comme assez tourné comme un comme
un court métrage comme un film à la
regarder ses joues beaucoup là dessus je
joue beaucoup sur cet
égard un peu transparent c'était là il
est particulièrement
bonne ont
effectivement effective et les fictions
et c'est aussi ça qui est fait qui a
fait et qui a fait sa renommée qui
montrent que aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
de gens comme on l'a dit au début du
live qui ont été très touchés finalement
par tam en
or étaient sagement et je crois que donc
il vivait une grande histoire d'amour
avec avec une mannequin professionnel
donc tu as que ça ça fait partie de la
légende je ne sais pas je suis pas sûr
je pense pas je pense pas que il était
fasciné par son par son rôle dans son
rôle publicitaires en revanche le road
publicitaire pour moi pour avoir connu
quelques quelques acteurs renommés et
moins renommés paradoxalement ça vous
permet d'avoir une aisance financière
une winneuse ans c'est le bon terme
c'est là que ça vous permet de choisir
un peu mieux vos rôles 1 vous n'êtes pas
parce que encore une fois nous jugent là
évidemment on juge toujours on essaie
toujours donner un sens et une
filmographie pourquoi tel film pour
coter le film le saltimbanque par
définition ils aiment tous jouer
ce jeu l'est et et vos regards
regarderai les plus grands comiques ont
joué des rôles tragiques et les les plus
grands tragédiens on jouait des parfois
même des nanars sans nom il aime jouer
il m
soit devant la caméra soit sur scène il
aimait se représenter ça c'est quelque
chose et d'ailleurs c'est peut-être là
le point commun est donc ils peuvent
tout assumer encore une fois c'est ce
qu'on disait il et il est capable de
jouer un héros il est capable de jouer
il est capable de jouer un soldat blessé
un autre film qui a compté sur lui qui
était moi mais c'est pas hasard ça peut
être y joue effectivement dans dans un
long dimanche de fiançailles et jouent
un jeu c'est un poilu parce qu'il est
trop jeune mais ça c'est en tout cas
c'est l'idée assez l'idée
et puis joue et il joue
quelqu'un qui vit l'exode un jeune homme
qui vit l'exode et qui vivait c'est en
1940 et donc et après il va jouer aussi
c'est aussi sec comment essayer de
donner du sens à tout ça il va jouer
aussi henri de guise le balafré à lui on
disait qu'il était balafré t il avait
une fausse avait eu avec créer une
fausse est qui et qui acquit à qui a
ajouté à son charme un s'étaient ajoutés
à son charme mais donc il y là il est
incarné est ce qu'il y a pensé à ce
moment là des personnages qui sont
emblématiques de l'histoire de france
henri de guise c'est évident le duc de
guise mais effectivement les gens qui
ont vécu l'exode c'est un moment c'est
un moment qui a marqué qui a marqué la
deuxième guerre mondiale en france en
tout cas évidemment les tranchées
n'était pas pour lui parce qu'il était
trop jeune mais il était en tout cas
combattants il joue un combattant un
jeune combattant alors on vous voit sur
ces images le cercueil qui devrait pas
tarder à sortir du corbillard pour être
amené dans l'église saint-eustache là où
va se passer la cérémonie qui devait
débuter à 11h je vais vous prendre
quelques commentaires chantal qui dit
paix à son âme toutes mes condoléances à
la famille repose en paix tu vas
rejoindre les anges dos il repose en
paix toutes mes condoléances à sa
famille anne qui nous dit gaspard ulliel
avec une élégance teintée de grâce
qu'ils représentaient oui c'est ce que
tu disais c'est qu il avait il avait
vraiment une tête particulière qui lui a
permis de s'imposer dans le cinéma et
c'est encore une fois c'est alors
surtout le connaît très jeune j'ai
essayé de trouver ce qu'il définissait
vous avez un caractère viril et juvénile
alors et avec un leurre a peut-être
effectivement un regard qui peut se
faire du rpt et en même temps un peu
perdu donc ça correspond un peu à tous
ces rôles et il peut jouer là il peut
jouer la date de sa un visage long un
visage un légèrement émacié quand même
un peu à couper au couteau aggravée
avec nom et puis
il jouait alors la proie il avait la
barbe de trois jours souvent c'était
l'été il était si la publicité
l'utiliser si le cinéma l'a utilisé
c'est qu'ils représentaient qui
représentait
james dean à représenter les années 50
60 et lévis les années 2000 qu'est-ce
que pourquoi ces frais ont été posés la
question au réalisateur qui le
choisissent parce qu'effectivement on
n'imagine pas surtout au début on fait
passer ils font passer des castings des
répétitions des auditions c'est une
compétition quand même deux pour
participer à ces grands films sur tout
aussi jeune si j'ai bien sûr sinon je
fais quand bien même ne font-ils pop
passer des auditions ils reçoivent des
boucs dit vérifient est au fond un
réalisateur c'est quelqu'un qui tout le
temps observe koné va voir des pièces de
théâtre veut aller à des pas des espions
cours florent mais pas loin i des
recruteurs mais non mais
c'est très important 1 c'est très
important dans poids pour un cinéaste a
le cinéaste c'est évidemment une 1 c'est
ce que disait gabas une histoire une
soeur une histoire mais c'est après
c'est un scénario et puis après ce sont
des acteurs qui vont incarner
parfaitement quelque chose le rôle qu'on
le rôle qu'on leur assigne donc acheter
de la question c'est de savoir qu'est ce
qui lui en trouver intuitivement au
début parce qu'une fois qu'il a il a
fait ses armes qu'il a fait trois quatre
films qui ont conquis ont marché qui ont
marqué qui ont marqué le public la
critique et le public
ça c'est fait je dirais c'est un peu
plus facile c'est un peu plus facile
mais au début les premiers films
pourquoi lui parce que qu'est ce qu'ils
ont vu en lui et moi je pense qu'ils ont
vu en lui une forme de de naïveté il
avait il y avait su en tout cas chez lui
très jeune une forme de candeur
tout à fait étonnante on n'a pas parlé
de son film qui lui a permis de
décrocher un
un césar qui était juste juste la fin du
monde de xavier dolan c'est quand même
une consécration pour tout acteur bah
c'est d'abord il a coincé en 2015 ou
2016 2017 2010 est donc il ya cinq ans
déjà donc il avait 32 ans
c'est
il joue un rôle difficile puisque c'est
quelqu'un qui revient dans sa famille
douze ans après et qu'il sait qu'il va
mourir donc la tragédie et là c'est
xavier dolan qui est considérée on voit
le cercueil juste que je vous coupe
bertrand hongrois le cercueil qui qui
rejoint l'église saint-eustache à paris
en ce moment même
les noirs
des applaudissements c'est encore une
fois pour les 7 d'avancé c'est pas c'est
pas
c'est pas maladroit s'est pas fait
partie on applaudit on peut applaudir
c'est que cercueil
quand ils entrent dans l'église est
plutôt en général ça c'est plutôt quand
il quand il sort nous la cérémonie qui
va débuter on sera bien évidemment pas à
l'intérieur de la cérémonie ne sera pas
ce qui se passe tu peux continuer
peut-être de parler de cette
delà du film juste ce film
paradoxalement
l'ua permet évidemment de de
recevoir le
plus beau l'appeler à la récompense
suprême française mais n'avait pas été
forcément bien reçu par la critique au
début bon on verra façon le beaucoup de
films comme ça qu'ils ont une vie après
après leur sortie est quelque chose qui
est ce qui peut surprendre un peu c'est
que la is a pris il avait tourné en tout
cas une série pour marvel qui devait qui
devrait sortir avant cette année normale
dans un mois dans un mois est
effectivement assez the moon knight c
est le chevalier de la lune en français
il est facile à traduire et gars là
dedans il joue pas je vous parle
premiers rôles il joue je crois le un
second rôle mais il joue lui le le
chevalier de minuit ou quelques j'ai
regardé ça
c'est sûr c'est que parce qu'il est
parce qu ils pas ce qui nous a quittés
ça va ça va être un événement tu es
toujours les et les sorties post mortem
un posthume c'est terrible forcément
s'en rappelle merci beaucoup en tout cas
bertrand d'avoir été avec moi pour
suivre ce c'est ses obsèques vous avez
pu voir du coup le
le camp bière qui est arrivé le cercle
qui est rentré dans l'église
saint-eustache la cérémonie se déroule
en ce moment merci à vous d'avoir suivi
ce live d'avoir poser vos question
d'avoir rendu hommage à ce grand acteur
qui était gaspard ulliel on va vous
passez les rôles les plus importants de
sa vie dans une petite vidéo qu'on va
vous passez maintenant merci encore à
vous d'avoir été là
où
quand mathilde émanait qu on fait
l'amour pour la première fois il s'est
endormi la main posée sur son sein
un matin d'août on était venu le
chercher
[Musique]
non
non folie une folie puisque nous sommes
donnés dans l'aude depuis tout sentiment
pour henri de guise ont trop éclatant
maîtriser les épouses et vous pensiez
laurent blanc comment entrer
à tous les châteaux supinya rendre ses
goûts ses humeurs
ce dont je veux parler votre beauté
notre bourg
je n'ai pas changé pas en train de
danser
vous regardez sa lutte il vous rappeler
qui est formé de votre époux le deuil
est une drôle d'épreuve un jour on croit
en est ressorti et puis nous est
toujours là
incrusté de sa colère
mon frère aussi et lui couper la tête
d'une certaine façon déjà même famille
des risques appeler
tu devras bobines pour nom c'est roberta
sanex ne lâcherai pas
ce qu'il ya des ennemis contre lequel on
ne peut pas lutter je parle de vous
de votre ennemi intérieur
occupez vous du vôtre et oubliez moi
[ __ ] tu fais chier 1 c'est sûr que tu
vas aller dans ce merdier
[Musique]